12 strong stars Chris Hemsworth Michael
Shannon and Michael Pena and tells the
true story of the horse soldiers men who
after 9/11 signed up to go and be the
first people to fight against the
Taliban the nation was obviously hurting
at the time and a lot of these men were
going to go on leave but after that they
decided no we're gonna go do something
about it and this is the Declassified
story of these 12 guys who are the very
first to fight back I would like in 12
strong two Michael Bay's 13 hours that
came out also in January also a war film
that has amazing action sequences but
weak character work 12 strong 13 hours
that's crazy I just thought of that
this movie is filled with committed
performances Chris Hemsworth is able to
escape that he looks like Thor thing he
does a very good job here especially in
the action scenes his face gets covered
by dirt and his friend that he's there
trying to communicate with who also
lives in Afghanistan who's giving him
information about where the Taliban are
he looks at him and says you've got the
killer eyes when he has this dirt all
over his face and he looks just angry
and filled with rage and there's a lot
of powerful moments like that
surprisingly in 12 strong that aren't
just about the war a lot of it does have
to do with Hemsworth trying to
communicate with people who are in
Afghanistan who also hate the Taliban
who are helping him find them and so
there's a little bit of a cultural gap
there because some of the men he's
communicating with they have their own
agendas as well they both want the
Taliban out but they both kind of want
it done in different ways and so that
aspect of the movie was kind of riveting
and I was glad they had the balls to
released it a sort of entertaining
feel-good way
explore some of those darker elements
despite the fact that some of the
Taliban they fight against kind of come
off like stormtroopers who can't aim at
anything the true story is served well
enough to the point where you have a
huge amount of respect for these men
when you leave the theater but I can
also understand from a film standpoint
how
it would be to depict danger to depict
that your heroes are almost going to die
when the true story says otherwise if
you don't know the true story I'll avoid
talking about it but it's like they did
a really damn good job but you still
have to have some fright and some scares
you have to feel like there's some
stakes even though these guys did some
amazing work but the writing for these
characters was unfortunately a little
basic they make jokes they tell dirty
jokes they say things that soldiers say
in movies and there doesn't really seem
to be that much of an effort to make the
men stand out but there's a definite
effort to make sure we understand the
danger of these men put themselves in
and while the film can come off a little
murky on the politics taking place it's
not a complete abandonment of them and
when I go to a film like this I don't
necessarily need all of that
sometimes just putting me in the fray
with the men and showing us exactly what
they went through or at least a fairly
accurate depiction of what they went
through that's enough for me I'm gonna
give 12 strong of B this January has
actually been okay so far I have yet to
see a terrible awful January film
there's been some disappointing ones but
as far as January's go this is
definitely one of the best so far I'm
actually feeling kind of good about this
we got a few more movies to see but
we'll see what happens guys thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get steppen eyes
[Music]